こんな外したそうですあのねぇいいねぇえええ
コラーゲンビーズ奴がありましてこれこれだけでお肌がツルツルになるんですけど
このビーズはどう見ても芳香剤のビーズなんですよ
でねこれねうはこれさては健介に仕掛けたらぜ太陽脆いやろうなぁと思ってやろうと
思ってるんですけども
いや待ってよこういうタイプの音立てながらユーチューバーで誰が先にやってそうだな
と思って見たら
アブいえ api と深みですだということであのバーンインチャンネルでやってまし
たね
ネタ被ってパクリパクリ言われるとちょっと嫌なので先に本人に許可を取っておきます
皆さんです papier どっ本 tease
ぷえーバーイ朝は家やません
場数がまでごお過ごした趣味です
なんかちょっとバンビ君にば意外というかお許しをいただきたくてですね
コラーゲン b'z っていう b ゾーンにつけてこれ芳香剤にデタラメっ
者芳香剤じゃねっと思ってやろうと思って youtube 調べたらああっっはれ
やってる人がいいなぁと思ってから版4チャンネルかっっ
やつね当日おですよねはい
僕も行っていいですかを競っていいじゃん
今月 n オープリー love ti sk 8近畿だいすきいいいいとして
ありがとうござい
あった糸いる許可を頂いたので合法的にパクっていきましょう
だって冷感日本と思いついたらかぶってるだけですからねそういうわけでも芳香剤の
容器を準備しました
女花はきれいに掃除してるんで大丈夫で鋼鋼材は本当に食べるとマジです次さんが
ポックリ逝っちゃうんで絶対芳香剤を食べてはいけませんっていう食べてはいけないの
を食べえって言っていい
一番面白いよね昔体ってあれホイールでも空取ってました時をすごい客様の方でまあ
そんな感じでやっていきました薄闇コラーゲンビールどんなのこと言いますと
見てぱっと見は大いくらなのよねぇなんか青いいくらボスしも作れるかなーと思ってた
んですけど plone これくれるんですよ
強い捉えるですから黄斑ないんですよ鉄血
ん
いわゆる無味無臭鉄ですこれをここに入れてよ
は見てもう芳香剤でしかない
me
が完全に芳香剤ですねこれはこれをやっ
どうですこの再現度もう大一によくある芳香剤になっているのではないでしょうか
僕と検事になりますと僕は何かテーション高まりすぎると鋼鋼材空タイプの人間だと
思われているんですよなのでもし何かもうノリノリになってこうやっている時にご飯が
いるんだから何か俺が
うんっ
さあ芳香剤食えんじゃねーとか言って大鋼材送りかねない人間だと後輩は思っていると
思うので今日は低床がやって方コード言った時の後輩のリアクションを見てみんなで
楽しめました
出合小窪経験交渉で4
4円もね持ったもを回してればね全然セイヴァール
ねパフェねーなんだろう何が金であるんん
方向にしてやろう早く
でも結構
[音楽]
ん
きゅんっ
ああああああ
最後ネック叫ぶや性
ずっと再生はい
7章者生還て一つあーうっていう
はいそれ9させるぬ
パート4レザー
の買うとか
味ことがつかせに行ってきますね
ブーバー色相いよ
またかぼちゃないだったらさねはーい
いいやつですかいい
tennai
写真集写真じゃないけどまず息を気がすんだろう
いやーダメですよ
ゆうですいやーねあんまりにはないん
消費税ですね山部時はから示さん
だし一応
ちゃんハァハァ
なぁ自分ミケ曲 t はないはぁっはぁっはぁっ
[音楽]
me
メジャーはツイッターだ俺い
[音楽]
ee a 食べられるの000
ウソでしょ1んん
[音楽]
でしょうねそうねそうそうでしょこれはー
ああああああ
ni
うわああああああ
ゲームだよ
なんでやそれそうですねって言う肌メイクだって大丈夫
えっ
うわぁヒューザーたじゃん hiroaki ましょう
だけじゃないですかだから入れた方がいいですよどうぞ
本日のピザも水
水を入場水は水のれつつ沿い
のっ
すっやばいっだよにへ
結構なローター会でもゲームやるがあっていろんな
もっとに組んでこれ食いのものが悪いとこれ
yeah
いやいや大丈夫すいませんじゃ
safe
強い馬でどうぞますか者が集まってやばい
アド前でどっち所ふふ0いやー
ええええええ
10水につけましょうん
嘘だようわぁ
me
teame
バッハ